in that meeting one day they said
basically every major government in the
world is effectively bankrupt I think
you're okay so all the people are
bankrupt all the governments are
bankrupt so who's got the money then and
obviously I'm sitting on this desk
surrounded by millionaires right and
that was like the penny drop moment for
me where you're like this is it this is
it this is what's happening isn't it
it's we're losing the middle the middle
class losing their homes government's
going bankrupt and it's going to the
rich and then and that's not going to
stop is it that's only going to keep
going so here you
go collapse forever that's the bet